one and your lighter
oh there that's better isn't it you can
hear me now
correct use of the microphones members
and officers um it is important that
when you wish to speak you turn on your
microphone
and when you finished speaking you turn
it off
just like i didn't do then
and i no longer have to draw your
attention to the different levels within
the chamber because they have
disappeared confusingly
so uh
there we are tara i have apologies for
absence please
good evening shannon thank you yes
apologies for receiving councillor
bastinger and councillor schemes thank
you chairman thank you very much
okay item three minutes it is
recommended that the very brief indeed
minutes of being held on the 28th of
october
found on pages five to six are approved
as a true and accurate
record
great
i'll second it thank you and i think we
have agreement
super thank you very much
assume four declarations of interest to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests other
pecuniary interests or non-pecuniary
interests relating to items of business
on the agenda having regard to paragraph
six to eight inclusive of the code of
conduct for members
and members are reminded that if any
interests arise during the meeting
they should um
disclose them then any any no no no
marvelous
i can advise that we have not received
any submissions from members of the
public this evening so i will move
swiftly on
to the mulder district community safety
partnership update which can be found on
pages 7-32 so mr clark i believe that's
you
thank you chair um purpose of tonight is
to give a brief overview of what the
community safety partnership has been
delivering over the last year
um i will not go into full detail
because i'm hoping members of the
opportunity to read the written report
in advance so i'll just go through the
the key areas
so on the on page on the 3.1 it goes
through the statutory duties and it
really gives an overview that the
partnership has gone through a data
review exercise and risk matrix exercise
to determine what the priorities will be
for this coming year ie 20 22 23
there are going to be no major changes
so the headline priorities which are
under 3.12
will remain the same as they have done
for the previous years but there's been
some slight changes to the narratives
around there so the additions on the
narratives are around the additions
around high harm offences
around uh domestic violence particularly
high-risk domestic violence uh violence
against women and girls
and uh also as the partnership we've
have been having some more discussions
around social isolation and uh poor
mental health and that links quite
nicely with the mold and live well group
as well so that's uh really just to
highlight what the priorities will be
for the partnership for the coming year
going down onto the next page um i will
again i won't dwell on this too much
because uh 3.14 really goes into the
policing update and i'll leave that for
chief inspector steve scott haynes to go
through um i believe he's probably got
the february update so the figures might
have changed slightly but perhaps they
haven't yeah but uh maldon still uh uh
is in a favorable
position when compared with other areas
in essex and members would have a cop a
copy of appendix one which is the
january uh figures
to review
uh it's worth pointing out there that um
as of district council we're still
getting uh quite a high number of uh
reports around antisocial behavior but
not as much as we were
just after lockdown
3.15 highlights sir what the
partnership's been doing around uh
preventing violent extremism i i chair
that essex prevent delivery group
got the next meeting on tuesday of next
week uh you'll see that the quarter-free
counter-terrorism local profile was
delivered on the 22nd of february and
recently the terrorism alert has just
been lowered to substantial because it
had been severe for a number of months
um sort of work that links in with this
is the work that we do with the
independent advisory group and also some
of the work i've been doing around the
protect duty um so that's continues uh
and uh also we do
tend to consider
hate crime at that particular meeting
because there is a clear link between
hate crime and preventing violent
extremism yeah absolutely
3.16 highlights where we are with the
public space protection order the
consultation has been has been completed
for that
the next steps for that is to go to a
final report to go to community services
committee uh then it will require a full
sign off by full council prior to it
going into force
um i think the the only other areas that
you're looking at is the notices which
require to be displayed as part of that
public space protection order so i'm
hoping that this will be live
um
in spring
this year cool i hope
that's with the current program
i haven't got the exact dates for what
committee it's going to but i'd like to
think that it will only be a period of
two to three months before it goes live
that's cool thank you brilliant um 3.2
goes on uh around the update on the
police and crime commissioner as we know
mr hurst was re-elected um last year
and uh is now um done an extension to
the police crime plan
which goes to 2024
that's available online
it's got 12
different priorities look very similar
to
what we were
looking at the previous plan
again i won't go into detail because
some of those areas are around votes
policing and we have mr pipes and that's
police and president tonight who can go
into much more detail than myself um
what you will see is there has been a
small increase in the precept for
policing and far again and uh that will
uh see about another 200 officers coming
into the force and again i won't go into
detail about that because mr scott
haynes couldn't
give an overview of where we anticipate
or what the local impact will be for
malden district
um
so
further on there you'll see the work
that you've been doing with the rural
engagement team and how that works quite
nicely with um the community protection
team at mouldon district council and you
also see that um
the moulton district council park funded
the jet skis which are being used by the
marine unit and uh if you check social
media they get very good reviews of the
work they're doing around policing our
coastline i do hope they're flushing all
that salt water out the engines so
they'll seize up like
just highlighting the work of the essex
violence vulnerability unit um i i i
sits the district rep from the
operations board for that um pleased to
announce uh i know i haven't put in this
report that uh
the full funding will be received for
the home office for the coming year
um and uh that's really good news so a
lot of the works around violence and
vulnerability will continue um for the
coming year
and then 3.3 gives a update on the hub
and the current work which we're doing i
have a cup uh under 3.31
there's a copy of the molden uh
community safety partnership plan on the
page
for members to look at just to give
doesn't give it in all detail because
members an idea of what we deliver each
year the last couple of years have been
somewhat strange but we're hoping to get
back to some sort of
normality this coming year particularly
the work which we're doing in the
schools
um
3.3 highlights the many uh
meetings attended by the team
whether it's mace or whether it's the
minister's children's partnership board
you'll see there's a extensive amount of
meetings with the partnership attend and
uh um represent molten district on that
3.3 i've highlighted a particularly good
piece of work
the community engagement offices
community safety engagement officers
which was a post which come into place
last year our representative is pc rosie
smith she's been doing a great job in
the district she does a lot of joint
patrolling with the community protection
team and uh the
the trial service uh role which looks
after the dengi so there's a lot of work
going on there
produces a very good newsletter each
month which is circulated to members um
and uh we continue to do some joint work
in some of the works been doing recently
is around in south minster bradwell and
haybridge looking at areas of concern
um
3.34 just gives a focus of where we've
been doing a lot of our work um a lot of
it's been
when you look at things like anti-social
behavior and hot spots tend to be about
the high street promenade park and hive
key but also some of the other areas uh
particularly uh when we've had the
couple of lockdowns there's been lots of
young people understandably so going
into public spaces um that that has uh
reduced somewhat and a lot of work's
been done with these young people
through the youth service and other
agencies
i did i did a flag up on the um
3.3 at the bottom there some other work
and this this this promise to do some
more work around social isolation
whereby our last uh strategic meeting
the station manager uh help pulling
attended and gave a really good
overview some case studies of uh fire
fatalities in malden district and uh
both both of these uh uh victims were
socially isolated and uh at hoarding
tendencies so uh we're linking in with
the mold and live well group to see what
we can do around social isolation and
how we can work with other agencies to
try and prevent such a
strategies happening again
3.35
you'll see i spoke about
the work we do in schools last year was
a very different year where we delivered
crucial crew virtually yeah
students um so that included a
pre-recorded drama around exploitation
and knife crime which is about 40
minutes long and the schools
got to view it and then they had an hour
uh facilitated session with the actors
to sort of
tease out what was happening and how uh
how people can make different choices um
we did the evaluation uh october time
and the schools want us back live this
year
so we've been welcomed back with uh open
arms what we're planning to do is work
with tick box productions today we'll do
it do the live drama in the schools and
then the partnership will be there to
speak with young people as a result of
that
other pieces work and this isn't all of
the work we do i've just highlighted
some of them been doing a lot of work
around uh
public engagement where we've been doing
some bike marking uh we do have another
uh event which you'll see there planned
for the 8th of april in promenade park
where invitations have gone out to a
number of partners again
we'll be doing bike marking but we'll
also be having other agencies there to
talk to people
um
and uh you'll see that we've done a
senior safety
event uh at malden football club on the
4th of october where we had about i
think there's 82 attendees to that
particular event and uh i think the
highlight of that event was the seated
exercise which was delivered by the ccg
you'll see that the youth youth service
or you've saw the youth strategy group
has commissioned a professional drama
called unacceptable which has been going
into the schools i know that's been
delivered at um ormiston rivers academy
and i think a revised date is being done
for plume
um which has been quite
well taken by the schools and then we
just highlighted some of the other work
which the community protection team
are doing around the districts
using truecam so at the moment we've got
working with uh 18 parishes at 45
different locations and that's linked up
with mr pipes team
through safer essex roads partnership
and uh
i won't go into all of these in detail
but you'll see that just gives a flavor
of some of the work that we're doing
uh things like the just play football
initiative which we do monday night at
the plume uh with the community
protection officers and young people so
that's very uh just a very quick
overview it gives members a flavor of
the work we've been doing i think next
year will be very different because
we'll be actually
being able to hopefully touch would uh
be able to get into get into the schools
and do more events which have been
restricted for the last two years
because of the pandemic
so um it's for members to know and
take questions chair
i'm pleased to say that we um now are
talking to ormiston rivers academy
whereas previously there have been some
issues around getting in there
i am meeting with the head joe williams
along with lauren green
the his commissioner
and gary dyer from the community
engagement team on friday
and they
so far the
oceans i've had from miss williams is
she's very very keen to do some
multi-agency working open up make the
school community half that
we would like it to be
and actually to to work with other
agencies so i'm
cautiously optimistic that we're going
to get some good stuff going with the
western
edge guys hopefully
um questions anyone
spencer
presentation
and um
yeah i mean you're doing some great work
in malden
average where
these two
um
thank you councillor hubner councilman
oh okay yeah thank you uh yeah it was a
good report when i finally got into the
thing
i got in a bit of a mucking puddle
um
yeah
i've i keep reporting to
well not so much one-on-one i tend to
grab any policemen i see you walking
along and i think i've got the rural
team
young girl come round a couple of days
ago and reported
where these drug dealers were dealing
from
giving new addresses and car
registrations and things like that like
you do it's a good neighbor
but i've noticed that we're getting a
few more of them gas
cylinders now in the walkway between the
plantation hall and going on to
hillary close
this only seems to be the last week i've
seen about five or six in there now
but i mean
the young lad who's dealing
i better not mention names because this
public thing in it
but basically uh
it backwards a ford's past mind like a
yo-yo
buff to have cameras put in the kitchen
and things like that but
what sort of
response do they do does it just go into
the intelligence and
they take action from there
uh counselor yep yes so uh please please
always report these types of activities
whether it's to the police or the
community protection team
we were doing joint patrols only a few
weeks ago
in that particular area and we have got
some interventions which we're looking
to looking to deliver there i won't say
about them publicly at the moment but
it's something we are looking to improve
that in that particular area and working
with the young people in that area so
please continue to report those and we
we we are aware of some of the issues
and we have increased patrols in that
particular area
so i actually watched
at least two well
the guys either on one of them really
fast scooters or walking around
and i mean i know what a dress he lives
at when he's dealing with um
a guy called uh i better not say that
either
no but it's it's to do with our uh ex
counsellor shall i say yeah
it's his nephew
i mean the police have raided her enough
times
but this other young lad is um
dealing on his behalf
um and i mean they're doing it in broad
daylight
i watched a guy when i was still talking
to one of the caretakers
about two days ago the guy sitting on a
bench someone come up shook his hand and
the way they went
i mean they're not even hiding there
sometimes they use that um
[Music]
shelter down at the bottom end of the
field
but most of the time it's just either
turns up on a bike or whatever quick
hand shaking and away they go
but i mean it's rife down there
that's because i lost a relative to
drugs that i'm pretty
uh intense on it
thank you
yeah thanks council i mean what i say
obviously the more information we've got
the more i can direct patrols into the
area i know that we have had a
number
of operations due to community
intelligence which have led us
to make some significant arrests and
recoveries of drugs um
we're not going to get everyone
as much as i wish we could um you know
because sadly some of them
you know don't have the rights on them
etc but um we will continue
executing warrants and we do it
regularly where we have enough evidence
to do so so the more information we get
the more i'm able to get those warrants
and um yeah smash down some doors
okay
yeah any vehicle that you see with um
rural
team on the side is um that is your
community but with your
response policing team
for malden
well we actually had um
my dad he didn't know where he was going
but
he's done that as well
thank you counselor you had another
question
yes i'm pleased to say report any crime
i'm also a crime stopper so
that's another avenue that um
we can uh go down as well and and knows
about that so yeah definitely
cool thank you thank you guys
oh yeah thank you mr chairman um i'm
from what i'm sorry paul's habit i'm
afraid
misgender me would you
okay are you gonna be a chin as well
um i was going home from what uh
councillor bill was saying about um
uh
lads dealing um perhaps have a look at
abby
turning
um
i come past that on a very regular basis
basis at various times of the day but
particularly sort of four to seven
o'clock
um
why are people down there in different
cars and they have no relationships some
of them are doing you know
talking
i didn't say that
um are doing other activities um
but some are clearly there for other
purposes
uh so that possibly needs to be
highlighted
i wanted to just talk very briefly about
uh neighborhood watch and where we're at
with neighbourhood watch in the district
um
and also
the event that is coming up on the 8th
of april
not any other day in april
and if you could just give give us a
little bit of information about that
please
thank you
mrs course sir councillor uh so we'll
start with the event on the 8th of april
um so uh uh claire hamrihan in in the
community safety teams organizing that
it's gone out to a number of uh partners
including crime stoppers you'll be
pleased to know so we hope to i think
crime stoppers are very keen on being
there yeah so uh
we did we did a did a similar event uh i
think it was july last year where we
done the bike marking um had lots of
different agencies there i think we had
the police cars there so uh the
youngsters like that love to come and
sit in the police car and
play with them
it's the same it's one of these
community engagement uh events which can
only really don't be done face to face
and it and it enables the public to come
and speak with a variety of partners um
so people like the youth service will be
there and it's it's a good opportunity
for us as a partnership to touch base
with people uh and um see what they want
so when we talk about
um young people uh
in areas causing problems we need to
determine
why and what they need and
and
the
essex uh
voluntary
service for youth young people have just
produced a really good uh listening
project which they've done for the last
three years where they actually speak to
young people
about what their concerns are and what
they actually want so things like
surprisingly young people want better
street lighting and more cctv cameras
but they also want
more youth provision
uh more provision which uh is open later
more variety so
well there has been a 73 percent cut in
funding to the youth service in the last
10 years
73
so that's not surprising really that
they're out in the streets sorry that's
why and that's why it's so important
that we speak with people at these
events you know and that's why we
deliver things like the just play
football initiative on monday nights
because we know that you know it doesn't
cost people anything they come along we
regularly get 20 young people
and it's not just about playing football
it's having that uh relationship with a
trusted adult sometimes they can't speak
to their
parents about issues and you know so so
that's the sort of thing we're trying to
encourage so
um hopefully a bit closer to the event
and we'll know who's attending and uh
how we can get out so that's a friday
eighth of april at promenade park
um
neighbourhood watch um
neighborhood watcher like a lot of
voluntary groups because uh doing the
pandemic has
been difficult
um we did uh successfully migrate um
neighborhood watch to microsoft teams
like most of our other groups for either
ran on zoom or teams
um we did see some of the membership
drop off we begin to see members come
back now
what we have done is uh
um
chelmsford and moulton neighborhood
watch are
sort of merged now in terms of the
funding and the
uh secretarial support to it
but we still have a separate chair for
chelmsford and a separate chair for
moulding so mandy chapman remains the
modern chair of neighborhood watch um
i think what we're looking to do
speaking to claire and our team this
week is
we're going to try and get some
face-to-face meetings back soon
some of some of the some of these do
work well on teams yeah but
i think
between the two absolutely i think and
that's what's not all of them with most
teams
you know some work really really well
but that balance is really important so
uh hopefully we get some more sign up on
the 8th of april they will be there
trying to get more sign up for members
um so
continue to do the work we still get the
reports we still send the reports out to
members so they can make local people
aware of what's happening which is also
important
so
it's uh there'll be a new drive for it
in 2022.
brilliant thank you you can come back
and make it consistently it's scattered
well all i'm going to say is i would
like to see as many members
attending this event
right now we've got our own event
happening in riverside park so
but certainly the the i should be
encouraging all um
based um and some of the periphery
villages
they'll be there excellent that's that's
concise and keep him away
thank you very much everybody that's
great so um
okay i am now going to hand over to
chief inspector scott haynes for an
update on
the police performance please thank you
either
that couldn't have been timed better
could it
be bear with
um can you right perhaps
thank you perhaps i might hand over mr
pipe to you then
chief inspector scott holmes is dealing
with an emergency by may okay without
putting you on the smith no absolutely
fine and i i did intend to send over a
presentation but um our systems essex
police have been down since one o'clock
so yeah
it's a day of sadly computer glitches
isn't it
yeah so i'm just going to give you uh
first of all my name is adam pipe i'm
the head of rhodes policing for essex
police which is traffic and old money um
and i look after 230 officers and staff
um across the command um just going to
set out what rhodes policing is all
about and what we actually have at our
disposal and a bit around your district
and then talk around what we're going to
be trying to do in the future around
something called vision zero so
um we've got 86 constables over two
roads policing bases you're covered out
of stanway with 43 constables
12 sergeants and two inspectors so just
to put that into context um stanway base
in effect covers the whole of the lpa
north so it's a massive geographical
area with at any time that could be just
one on seven officers on duty
so it's quite a significant geographical
area for a relatively small number of
officers
um
they'll attend on average about 1700
incidents a month
most of them road related but they do
form a role that supports local policing
as well
roads policing now is not all about
traffic offences road safety it's very
much a part of that but rhodes policing
is also about disrupting criminality and
criminal use of the road
so we know that most offenses and most
harm that comes to the district is very
much through the use of the car whether
it be burglary
um
and even like violence it's how um class
a um is brought into the to the county
into these districts as well so rhodes
policing is very much about
disrupting criminality but also trying
to make our roads safe and that's what
we're all about so the other base at
chigwell with again 43 officers covers
really everything else other than the
lpa north but you can again see that
geographically it's a massive area
i also look after a team at southwood
and ferris
which is the road crime team and their
focus is very much on disrupting that
criminal aspect of people that use the
roads
with 14 officers and two sergeants i've
got a commercial vehicle unit at south
wooden which is four officers and again
they're focused very much on the safety
of commercial vehicles heavy goods
vehicles but now they're very much into
organized crime um particularly
immigration crime modern day slavery
human trafficking
um and they get called out regularly to
the lorries that are coming into the uk
with people into the back of them i've
got a team of 14 special constables at
woodham as well and also oversee road
deaths on with the team at uh based at
borum so a relatively small team
we did suffer during the periods of
reductions in policing
but we're back on the up which is really
really good news but every day remains a
challenge when we have to sort of
respond to lots and lots of incidents on
the network road traffic collisions but
then also try and provide that
preventative message as well
so we're very lucky in essex that we
have road safety both on the force plan
and the pfcc's plan which is absolutely
fantastic news um there are many forces
across the country that don't have that
and road safety and roads policing is
not at the moment on the government
strategic policing plan although that is
likely to change
if we look at what happens in the malden
district so
if i tell you
last year we had about 790 people killed
or seriously injured in road traffic
collisions but about which around 46 of
those were fatal we've already had in
since the start of january 15 people
killed with the most recent being last
night over in waltham abbey
um so just when you think of the figures
i'm about to give you it she puts it in
some kind of context so last year there
was 36 people in the malden district uh
killed or seriously injured um
thankfully um i believe on that was only
two people killed although it's too too
many but um just to put into some
context
the highest year over the last five
years has been 2018 with 55.
so
and 2020 was 30 2019 30 and back to 2017
with 34. so when we talk about serious
injury we were talking about it could be
a break of a bone right the way up to a
loss of a limb
um and a fatality is anything that's um
someone has died within 30 days of a
recorded road traffic collision so each
one of those deaths in particular
leaves
trauma to the family
and colleagues of the people that have
been lost
we know at the moment the cannabis in
cocaine is playing a massive part in
road traffic collisions if i tell you
that one in three of our fatalities
normally within that particular incident
at least one person has cocaine or
cannabis in their system
we're arresting about 120 people a month
at the moment for drug driving for
cannabis and cocaine um and sadly it's
an all too i think with a bigger feature
we see every single day on the roads of
essex um but something we really intend
to to crack on
as we move into this year
with some additional capacity that's
been brought into the national forensic
science service so we'll be able to do
more more arrests
that's also good because we also know
that those that take drugs and driving
cocaine and cannabis have previous
convictions for other criminal offences
so when we do some studies about 56 the
percent of the people we arrest for drug
driving have previous criminal
convictions the biggest group linked to
violence
so again rhodes policing has a big part
to play with disrupting that type of
activity
so those are the numbers in the malden
district and if we look then at the ages
of those um not and this is no surprise
the the largest group falls within the
16 to 25 year olds
which is historically what we would see
right across the county
and right across the country
um and then if we look at
the modes of transport this is quite
interesting because 92 people have been
killed or seriously injured using a car
but where you're quite high is powder
wheelers which obviously you've got some
very attractive roads out to the dingy
peninsula so 41 of those collisions over
the last five years have been
motorcyclists 21 pedestrians and 19
pedal cyclists
so absolutely we're aware of what the
road routes are like out towards the
denture peninsula
in the summer months
and we will be doing as we did last year
the the teams at woodham the motorcycle
units they go out on these routes on
saturdays and sundays and they take
positive action using marked bikes and
unmarked bikes
um
not just looking at bikes but also
looking at cars and those routes also
extend into the lpa north so going up
into adulthood and the braintree
district as well and parts of the b1022
speed plays a massive factor in road
traffic collisions it's the second
highest contributing factor in our
recorded collisions
the first being generals type of
careless
observational type stuff but speed is
massive and if i was to change that
round to just put the contributive
factor for
young people so 16 to 25 speed will come
out as top
so
we know
young people that's car drivers and
passengers are really vulnerable um and
your town
and i live in malden so i see it as well
no different from any other market town
it attracts the
young drivers that meet in the car parks
like tesco's and then use a bit of a
circuit
uh which poses a risk but if i tell you
that
um we have to police events uh mainly in
furrock basildon south end
where we're seeing hundreds of cars so
it's quite routine for us to go to
furrock on a saturday night we'll be in
excess of a thousand cars meeting
driven by social media
we've got we don't have that no not
right it's just very good to put in some
good context
but a lot of the people that will be
taking part in some of the events in
malden and other market towns will be
those that go to these events as well so
that's the type of risk they're driven
by social media
they're spontaneous they're very
difficult to police because we don't
know necessarily where they're going to
take place but we do have plans in place
all the time for a response procedure
involving roads policing officers and
community policing team officers we're
also aware of the meets at places like
south hampfield
and over aberton
which are
straight stretches of road which are
used by car cruise groups so they're a
very very vulnerable group
um
move on to the next one
so you'd have seen it
over itself
um so
what we're going to be doing so what's
happened in essex really is that we have
made some really good reductions in
ksi's so killed and seriously injured
over a number of years but we've
plateaued
so we are going with our partners from
the safe 406 roads partnership into
what's called vision zero
so by 2040 we're looking for zero road
deaths and zero serious injuries from
road traffic collisions
which you might think
it's very ambitious however when i
started 20 odd years ago
we were recording 130 140 people killed
every year
and around about 1300 1400 people
seriously injured so we've already come
a long way
and we've come a long way for a number
of reasons probably in as much that
vehicle safety has become a big part of
it so it is ambitious and we're not the
only force going to be doing this in the
only partnership so metropolitan police
and transport for london kent
hertfordshire police scotland so the
whole stance across the whole country is
moving towards division zero
that is going to have to be a total
change of how people think about using
the road network
and it's underpinned by what they call
the safe system approach
and the safe system approach will really
look for district councils county
councils to start really thinking about
how they plan
out the possibility of road traffic
collisions on developments
housing developments new developments
new roads
or existing roads
and and speed and the enforcement speed
is going to be one of the absolutely
most important parts of underpinning
vision zero
essex county council at the moment are
redoing their speed management strategy
and their route hierarchy and it is
likely we're going to start to see speed
limits that we probably haven't seen
before because the hierarchical changes
in highway code are meaning that
vulnerable road user groups are going to
get a greater level of priority
so it could be some routes which are
predominantly used by cyclists or
pedestrians which are going to be rural
roads in the main
could come down from d restricted so 60
to perhaps 50 or 40.
you will potentially see a greater roll
out of 20 mile an hour speed limits in
urban areas
um and a whole host of other changes so
um
and
we will need to be doing more speed
enforcement transport for london the
metropolitan police are going to
increase their enforcement from a
quarter of a million offences a year to
a million by 24-25
to underpin vision zero
so
speed is going to be a really big part
other parts of it are safe vehicles
because we know that vehicles
continually become safer and safer
how we look at our post collision
response and when you consider
potentially over the last 10 years that
we are now with the use of
the ambulance service helicopters
how we're now doing operations of the
roadsides and really putting in that
critical hour where you've got
interventions at the roadside that we
wouldn't have done just over 10 years
ago
without doubt some of those
interventions are saving lives without
doubt
and that will continue um
when we talk about um
safe roads and safe roadsides this is an
opportunity like we try and design our
crime in new schemes we need to try and
design out collisions and possibility of
casualties
um
and i've had conversations with richard
before there's real opportunities we're
going to see such significant
development over essex over the next few
years that
we need to really consider what
developers are building and what it
actually means to the local area as to
how we enforce what is left once they
have gone
um and in particular the introduction of
average speed cameras
on a wider
scale
we will continue to have challenges in
enforcing
speed um but really we want to have an
environment where we have things in
place to ensure that vehicle speeds are
appropriate to the roads
and potentially using average systems so
you know within the planning stages
please start to think about possibility
of average systems being put in on new
roads or developments
so that we can absolutely get a level of
compliance with the new speed limits are
going to come in now if we take malden
high street and obviously i know i'm
local and i know the 20 and i know
there's an intention to get 20 miles an
hour on the high street and market hill
we need to really think about how that's
going to be enforced um
20 mile an hour are really difficult to
enforce without a significant level of
enforcement or the ability to actually
force vehicle speeds down to 20.
there are average speed systems now on
the market which can be done over 75
meters in distance
and can blend in with the local
environments they're not the sort of
things you see on the m25 or or on the
a12
so there are products out there that
would give you a level of compliance
without the need for police intervention
or
our local authority colleagues from
northern district council who enforce
because that's the type of um that's the
type of movement we need to start moving
towards um
as we as we try to go towards vision
zero
so radical changes ahead um gonna need
everyone to have a totally different
mindset on how we look around how we use
the road with a greater emphasis on
those
more vulnerable road users
there is something else we do already as
well and something that perhaps we could
start to consider in malden um we have a
really successful what they call extra
eyes system where mems the public can
send in digital images of anything they
see on the road which is dangerous or
poor behavior
we get about 330 clips a month from
drivers and cyclists who see something
on the road which is just not right
um we could take that from cctv as well
so cctv and modern high street or any
other local authority cctv if there's
something that the operators see in
chelsea when they're monitoring it that
they don't like that is dangerous
we can deal with it
and we've got some real success over in
clacton where we successfully prosecuted
about 12 people on an industrial state
using cctv
all for car cruising and racing on the
highway so any sort of dangerous
careless type road user behavior we
could deal with on the externalized
product
high success rate we have our own court
once a month where people go to court
and the magistrates
really um don't like what they see and
they're sending out some really strong
messages
so just finally
just a couple of things that are going
to really again make a difference in
road safety the mobile phone legislation
will be updated on the 25th of march
which will come into
place
we have had difficulties enforcing
mobile phone use since august 19 when
there was a um
an appeal successful appeal against the
use of a mobile phone and it's all
because really that technology continues
to rampantly progress
and how we use a mobile phone and the
legislation hadn't caught up with that
so lots of loopholes are being tidy up
and uh and that will come into being on
march 25th the most
significant thing though as part of the
um police court's crimes and sentencing
bill there is a section there that the
there will become a life-term tariff for
death by dangerous driving aggravated by
drink or drugs
so that's going to be coming in and i
believe it's for royal ascent this month
so that is a real significant change um
and we've probably had two recent cases
where if that tariff was in
they would have been heading towards a
lifetime tariff um both got 12 and 14
years respectively but um probably would
have been considered for life term
terror advice
so
lots of things happening small team lots
more we can do and lots more we want to
do with yourselves the the partnership
we've got more than district council is
fantastic
the chief constable recently reviewed
the working relationship and was
satisfied that he wants to carry on um
doing it with modern district council
just to give you an idea in
february there were 47 deployments by
your team
capturing 166 offenses now this
yeah yeah so this is this is not all
about catching people so
you know this is about um being seen so
166 is great but if they went and got no
one it's more about being seen and they
are going to locations which are simply
brilliant for
rural safety acknowledging actually
the most of our serious and fatal road
traffic collisions happen in a rural
environment so they're making a
fantastic contribution
um and other forces across the country
come and talk to us about what that that
type of uh use of power so it's really
really good
um that's probably it because i could
ramble on forever if i'm allowed to but
i probably won't
thank you very much um
i'm going to come in first
i'm a biker
um
pedal cycle
that motorcycle and i have
i have a very big problem with vision
zero
as do the motorcycle action group who
you may or may not do
and i'm wondering if you've looked at
the welcoming roads manifesto that's
been produced by um
the motorcycle action
which they describe as some
an evolution
of vision zero which seeks to preserve
the success successful aspects whilst
shedding unhelpful baggage
now vision zero as such just excludes
motorcycles completely because we're
never gonna have a zero
fatality
um but again well we say that so vision
zero is an aspiration but again like i
said a minute ago when i we first joined
we had motorcycle fatalities
in i mean those that 130 at least half
of those would have been motorcycle
fatalities they still equate for 26 of
our overall ksis that's not just their
success nationally so we have come a
long way
um and
it probably will be one of our most not
not challenging in the right way of how
we're going to get towards vision zero
for the motorcycle community so i think
we just need to keep looking at where
we've come from and where we want to get
to
because we have made some real
significant and
you know and
what we're looking at we're doing at the
moment a total review of our speed
management strategy
because the speed management strategy
we're going to be putting in is probably
going to try and afford more protection
on routes that are used by our more
vulnerable road user groups so i've got
a member of my staff moment who is
engaging with people from various
vulnerable groups which will include the
motorcycle community
so it may be that we put a greater
presence on some of the routes after
burnham at weekends not just to protect
yourselves but also we know that cycles
cyclists use the routes at weekends
out on the dingy so there'll be a
greater focus and that's something we
haven't done before
and i'd say we when we go out on those
routes there's a lot of public
confidence around what they believe and
perceive to be motorcycle issues we
actually catch more car drivers
very often it's the perceived issue as
opposed to that
we are absolutely in the early days of
vision zero and we will have a lot to
learn
um but we will need everybody to come on
board and engage with us and work with
us because if we can't achieve this on
the right so um we did used to have at
the county council and through our
partnership where mag used to come on
board and have chat to this so i'm not
sure if they do anymore but i think the
problem is we don't have we don't
currently have an essex mag right okay
we don't there's a south east one but
they meet in kent so there's no actual
i'm too busy otherwise i probably would
but um
yeah i mean so could i could i ask you
to take a look at welcoming
and see how we can um yeah i'm more than
happy to
send you the link button i'm sure you
can google it
so it's a sensible
it's a really sensible way forward so i
think perhaps if we could have some kind
of
elements of that put in as well and i'm
more than happy to um
talk to you about this from a motorcycle
get information within the safety ethics
roads partnership the fire service lead
on our motorcycle safety
so they've done the fire bike
i've done a couple of the um it's really
difficult but really it's not good yeah
no thank you very much for that
that's nice
thank you um
yeah really interesting um some really
good work i know i'm a hot on truecam
love truecam want to see more of it
um
and yes the 20 mile an hour is difficult
but there are places that it can be done
we need to be targeting
um
in our high street right now
whenever we do we get good results and
yep
we uh
there's a lot of action on on facebook
um where do you feel or if if you feel
anything at all or have any view on
speed watch
which is another element that i'd like
to see
more actively uh engage with in in the
town but also in some of our rural
villages i know it exists
um i've been having some conversations
with um
janet
yes
experts in the uh i know i know i know
that there are you know that you have to
have 10 people and all the rest of it
um it's currently being run by
87 year old which is
not ideal we need more people involved
with it we need younger people involved
with it we need to be higher profile and
easier to actually access
um help
okay so thank you
again the fire service have taken the
lead um on this um and it is working
since since we've come out of cove it's
working quite well so we've got 120
groups now with 1200 volunteers
and we're trying to get three groups
live every single month because we've
got quite a few people that need to come
on board i know there's big backlogs
yeah so we are getting through that
backlog so it's a very much done in the
spirit of essex county council road
safety officers are also involved in the
training
so we can get groups live the fire
service lead which then leaves us to
come and do some of the enforcement so
absolutely we want more groups to to
come on board um
we
we always have struggled with the level
of expectation and what what community
speedwatch groups of what they want and
what they ultimately expect
what we've always struggled on is giving
them that level of support to come and
do some enforcement alongside them from
time to time
so we've got
sorry i'm going to jump in there and say
jump in there and say
can that work with trucam for example
so
so first of all
the chief council's made it very clear
we will not be giving truecam any
enforcement for enforcement purposes to
volunteers
okay but i do know yeah but i do know
that you know the modern district
council
community protection officers can go and
support those groups and i think they do
because some of the sites are similar
we are about to we've got an uplift on
some posts which will start to improve
our ability to go out and do some more
enforcement
um so within the speed management
strategy there's some additional posts
coming online so we will have an ability
to go out and service some of those
groups more so they'll go out to
community speedwatch groups as well as
some of those groups we were talking
about a minute ago around some of the
routes for vulnerable road users and
enforcing some of our historic sort of
ksi routes
so that is definitely going to help us
put the vision and support back out
there and probably meet some other
expectations
um
but we will never be in a position where
volunteers will be able to enforce
it will always be a monitoring but it's
just how we can start to further improve
that level of confidence that how we're
sort of being seen to support
yeah that's right there's another device
which i know um we've spoken about
previously we we're just about and we've
just started using a new device similar
to truecam but we can actually use at
night so it's based on the same
principles of truecan but we can use it
in the dark which is a game changer
yeah so stanway our road piecing unit
just taken delivery they've got 18
people just been trained and they've
started to use it so again for places
like northern high street and some of
the other rural areas the causeway
culture's the road golden road is going
to be ideal
again we don't want to catch anyone but
it's a tool that can be used to really
address some of the sort of most at-risk
areas
we need to start slowing some of these
drivers down
and yes i think your your age bracket is
is the target um the other thing i
wanted to ask you about and i you know
maybe point me in the right direction is
towards
you you talked earlier about um i think
they're called vas's or vases i'm not
not familiar with them um but is that
you know they're the 30 miles an hour
they smile maybe they've got smiley
faces or they
they got their numbers or whatever
are they useful tool or are they just an
expensive toy
um so i think they had their place
however drivers are very aware that over
time there's they just look just like a
warning really and and they probably
lose their their impact
they're probably better if they can be
moved around so they're not in one
permanent place but really i think now
the technology
is old and it's moved on if i go back to
the average system
there are
in time
you know you could have an average
system over a very very short distance
which will give you total compliance but
there's no better speed enforcement
measure than average speed system and
technology is there now you mean
you could have an average system over 75
meters only
um which would give you a very strong
level of compliance
and that's got to be the way forward
briefly councilman
would something like that work in the
high street
100
talk later
anyone else have any questions
for uh
cathy hoover yeah so um i agreed with
everything you said and um
you know it's the old adage when
uh
all people die
and have accidents because
they're not they cannot stop in the
distance they can see clear and you know
that i know that i was a class one
driver so everything that you talk about
is
spot on yeah
yeah tragically um
there are very few fatal road traffic
conditions that we we deal with where
it generally says like it's a genuine
accident
um and you know the consequence and the
tragedy
not only from the victims and the
families but actually the officers
um my officers see far too much tragedy
and it does affect them
and we have to really think about what
they see
um because it does we just leave them
and we've got some very very young
workforce at the moment um and it's it's
tough
but yeah i i just wish people could
start to realize that tragedy and that
loss that's that's that's there and that
will be happening this morning after the
fight a bit more from heavy
thank you
briefly if you would i'm keen to him
come it's chief inspector scott haynes
before his phone goes off again
you know i don't do briefly
uh well i know you say it's out of date
but i'm always getting smiley faces i
think it's a psychological
people like like the fact that they've
got a smiley face
um
it's all well and good catching all
these people but i thought it's probably
i don't know it's do the police
did the police have any sort of say in
the
cps the point i'm trying to make is how
long are all of these queues for courts
now you know if we're going to be
catching all these people like
it could be like 10 years time is if we
take you to court
so
one of the things that happened a few
years ago as you probably know you could
be referred on to driver improvement
scheme so the idea of that was to take
out a large number of people that are
deemed to be low end offending
and taking them out the criminal justice
system so it doesn't clog up the
criminal justice system but also puts
education back into those people that
offended the lower lower end
so there definitely are delays in the
school system at the moment um we've
just had some fatals that have gone to
court which were four years old
but um but um our court backlogs now are
far better than they were um we're
bringing people to justice quite quickly
um i've speaking to my team today billy
ricky and you know they're booking court
cases for careless into the months of
may which is brilliant this previous set
would have been a bit further ahead than
that so yeah it's something you know
we're constantly looking at but that's
not a problem
that legislation there with the tariff
will be fantastic for life term for for
some other and and we've had some recent
results in court where the
the sentence is absolutely spot on for
the seriousness of the events
i must admit i've no i'm aware of the
new rules with cyclist and pedestrians
and whatever
and keep getting in my way
but basically
i've seen quite a bit because obviously
i'm not
you know a marked police car the public
do see a lot of rubbish going on like
not waiting for pedestrians cut and all
the bikes all that sort of stuff
i mean i'm starting muttering up but it
don't do much
but um
so that that was that point
and the other thing i was going to ask
was
it doesn't take a brain surgeon to work
out that unmarked police cars are going
to see a lot more
than all the stripes and
if they could be kept for
things like road accidents
and serious cases but have a few i'll
say a few more a lot more unmarked
police guys you're going to catch a lot
more people
i mean you see around that roundabout by
tesco's
it's like center pod
at a certain time of night
you know you know the times i'm talking
about
and the thing is if they see a police
car they're going to slow down
that's rather the point though isn't it
well the point is it would be nice
people we want to stop them it doesn't
matter how we stop them as long as we
stop yeah but if there's an unmate mark
police car they're going to catch a lot
more people
because they're not looking they're not
looking out for an unmarked police car i
know it's underhanded
not that we catch them so if they see a
mark police car they slow down job done
yeah but you know that if they're
speeding like some sort of muppet
nine times out of ten drugs are involved
trust me
we do operate are marked unmarked and
marked bleep so the 13 cars out of
stanway uh three of them are unmarked
restaurant and there's a miles fleet
down at southwest so we do use those
tactical options depending on what we're
going for and i do know the team from
stanway were over here i think only last
week in the evening and they did stop a
number of vehicles that were linked to
that type of activity talking about
and just finally we we are to sort of
address some of that behavior we just
invested 1.5 million pounds for the pfcc
into
the entire fleet within operational
policing command which includes roads
dogs um
armed response we're all going to have
um axon fleet 3
cameras in the cars so forward and rear
because at the moment we don't have
cameras in our cars
so that's going to be a real game
changer as to how we deal with some of
the offences that we identify
thank you
sorry i'm on a roll now you got me going
it's basically as you know
very soon we've got to make a decision
on the moulton police station
whether it's going to become businesses
or whatever
i'm a firm believer in that if you have
local police i mean i know you said that
the building was out a day and it the
technology wasn't there whatever
but now if you arrest someone they've
got to go to basildon you couldn't go to
champs because you've refurbished it all
but it seems to me
a false negative and as much as you've
got no holding cells or anything locally
i mean we can bishops shut i don't know
if burnham still got a police station
you've you've moved on to inspector
scott haynes questions now counselor b
or you've
got you're ahead of yourself
chief inspector would you like to answer
that
let me answer that and hope the phone
doesn't go yeah
isn't it so um
the estates issue within essex police is
something that is out of sight
of my control
um what was modern police station it's
been sold we no longer own that site
there's nothing we can do about that on
the other hand part of the the
information i'm going to give you
tonight is the expansion of our space
here at the um council offices
which has now been agreed
and the space has been identified which
will double off at print and also
an increase in policing
numbers through the
town center team
being increased as a community policing
team so
we are looking at these as to custody
spots
um the investment in our custody blocks
has been phenomenal um
it's taken a lot of money for us to get
all of ourselves up standard chelsea
police station is now open
um
all 15 sales are open as part of that
refurbishment we've put cctv cameras on
so that we spend less time with our
officers literally babysitting people
who are in custody and have um issues
but that's medical or mental
health issues so we continue
to invest in the right places so
someone arrested
in
malden dengi area will probably go to
chelmsford
but could go to any station in the force
because that is the right thing to do so
that we put people where they are but um
investment wise
yes there was a move away but that has
certainly increased then as i go through
my piece i'll fill you in on more
details of that
thank you so can we um
can we go to you
now did you have a question
richard
another question just just to inform
that we were already having discussions
around average speed cameras um with
adam around new planning development so
that's started
and i'm quite interested to explore the
there's a mobile average speed camera
through work this uh community safety
partnership so it's on our list of
discussion points
excellent thank you
so yes in the hope the phone doesn't go
off again over to you chief inspector
thank you thank you chair and my
apologies for two phone calls
unfortunately on the course duty officer
at the moment as well
so um
modern policing um
okay i'll step back a bit after the
counsellor's question and and start with
the good stuff that's coming um to try
and
get through that um since i got here
first as your community policing team
inspector
um
three years ago
it seemed like five minutes now as the
district commander from day one i've
said i wanted a community policing team
presence back in malden
um and i fought for that and fought for
that in the latest precept
i have received where there are 78
officers being brought into the force
specifically
to
increase town center teams
um
i've got five of those
four malden
so i've got a sergeant
and four pcs who will join the two pcs
we currently have which will give us
one sergeant and six
as a proper community team established
here in malden covering the whole of the
area and the benji
to go alongside that
with
mr holmes's excellent help we have now
identified
um had all the budget and everything
agreed to double the footprint of the
police presence here
um so
it's taken three years but we're there
we've got it
so that's the first thing so that's
a really good piece of news for us and
one that we've really pushed for
um
how are things going how we currently
looking um i've got january's figures um
sadly because februaries haven't come
through to me um we have seen a crime
increase um a fully expected crime
increase
on holiday yes
fully expected crime increase with
lockdown um easing
we knew that crime had severely gone
down significantly gone down um at the
end end of january our percentage
difference was just under one percent
increase
in crime
the force has had seven percent increase
in fight crime
so we're still significantly lower than
the force
and that will continue to be per head of
capita um we've got the second lowest
crime rate in the county
um
following on from oxford
any increase in crime isn't good we
don't want to see it but we we fully
expected it what we have seen though is
this massive decrease in antisocial
behavior we know a lot of that is around
the change to coded restrictions
but a 37
decrease over 400 less incidents
reported to us at the police i know that
as a council some of you have taken some
of those over
the types of crimes that we've seen
reduced come down are the what we call
state-based crimes so these are the
crimes where there is not a
specific victim
so
um
if we find someone holding drugs
if we find someone holding an offensive
weapon um
public order offences
those defenses have come down
that fits with lockdown less
interactions etc etc sadly the offences
that have gone up
have been around
bonners with injuries
um
stalking and harassment
very much
domestic related offenses we have seen
go up
what we didn't see which we all expected
was this to be
kind of an explosion
of domestic violence it didn't happen
like that
there was a slow creep and it hasn't
been as high numbers as we expect it to
be
any increase is bad increase
yeah which um
stun that
what we have also seen is a massive
decrease in burglary particularly
residential burglary again fully
expected people are living at home
um through the lockdown but that isn't
changing at the moment
so
we're not seeing that creep up
so
that's um continuing
um
back from vehicles theft or vehicles
gains still low
which strangely has seen an increase in
chelsea
so just down the road we're seeing an
increase in that that hasn't come this
way as of yet
um
criminal damage offenses are now
starting to creep up which again we
would expect as people are coming out
again so
um
the things that are going on with the
the team at the moment um ongoing
reports uh we've gone vehicles driving
and socially we've covered this quite
significantly
um the community policing team
did an operation in february which led
to two vehicles being seized that was
particularly centered around the high
street
so you're aware
um ongoing operations in around malden
and the district for drug dealing um
we've had an increase in our stop and
search and intel gathering
most importantly out of that
are
positive stop searches are running
around 33
the national average is 25
so the information we're getting from
yourselves
is pointing us to the right people more
often than not
so when we're doing those searches which
are intelligence led yeah we're getting
the results we want from them
so those sorts and they not it may not
always be drugs that we find it may be
that we find a weapon it may be
that actually we don't find anything but
we discovered that this person is wanted
so that would be a positive outcome
um
we continue with our partnership work
around just
disrupting drugs lines as i've explained
before in the in this area we have got
much more of a homegrown drug issue as
opposed to county lines coming in
chelsea very much county line based
ours is much more homegrown much more
along the lines of cocaine use rather
than crack and heroin heroin
i can say that
um but again
we're having some significant arrests in
relation to that
um obviously we're planning the day of
action we're coming to that
so aware of that
um
we've also had an increase in any social
behavior
concerns around rural areas and over the
last four weeks the team have been
working on that
and um that those anti-social behavior
reports have started to reduce now
which we're seeing
we've also
redesignated some officers to the high
schools because we've had some concerns
about anti-vaxx protesters attending
schools although that was quite
short-lived yeah so
but
they are the main points
what i'd add is we do our confidence
survey on a quarterly basis
and
the key findings from that
which
helped me to see that we are aiming at
the right things
so confidence in receiving a good
service from the police
is at 75
that is the highest it's been since
december 2018.
so it's increasing
police in the area are doing a good or
excellent job is at 83 which is the
highest it's ever been at in the malden
district
it's encouraging if you let crime and
social behavior have come more of a
problem that's reduced down to 23 the
lowest it's ever been
so again that's um moving the right way
feel informed about that the police are
doing in my local area
we
last month
we had
the last time this was done that was at
63
we've had a significant drop down to 47
so
i'm failing in getting that message out
and there's been a change in the last
quarter i don't know what that is
because
our newsletter has continued our social
media footprint has grown
our coffee with cops is now back we've
had that yeah
yeah there's something i'm missing and
getting that message out so any
suggestions i don't know what it is
would be
gratefully received because i i i
thought we were there
ask around the community what are we
going to do
just sorry just a little bit before we
move on from the figures a little bit
concerned about the um
i've lost it now um race racial and
religiously aggravated offenses yeah
shocking increasing yeah
a huge increase up by 23.
what are the actual numbers though
so the actual because it's related to
the actual numbers isn't it you know if
you go from one to one to two
sixteen thirty nine sixteen three yeah
okay quite big yeah that's quite big
it is quite a big 143
yeah um
yeah the first part of the answer i'm
going to give is
in some respects it's pleasing because
we're getting them reported yeah that
has certainly changed we know it was
an area that was massively under
reported and we can see that by last
year's figures that
that's massively underreported
we know we have had um specific
issues around a couple of premises shops
where shopkeepers have been um abused
um certainly one in the high street
um
really which was yeah oh which was
children
oh god so um being abusive to stall
keepers
um
we're trying to redirect in those cases
yeah um
one of the things that we
have really tried to build
across our iag and counselling you'll
know this because again i asked the
question at our last iag
we don't really have a link with um with
the gay community either in malden or in
the chelsea side at our independent um
advisory group and we know some of these
offences are through that right so we're
trying to develop those links so that we
can see
a way we could do building about that
prevention yeah so
um so yeah
a concerning increase but some of that
increase is because people are prepared
to come forward and tell us about it
thank you and i mean it's positive that
we're getting into schools because
that's where it needs to happen isn't it
we need to talk to
well yeah get them whilst they are young
thank you
yeah all i was going to say was i'm a
bit concerned about you talking about a
store in in the town um and a racial
or hate
um
aggravation abuse whatever
um
and it being young people
we need to are we liaising with schools
on this i mean i'm you know i'm
teaching you to psychics i'm not not i'm
just asking the question that that is
being looked at actively
absolutely so
there have been
um
this particular issue um another issue
that the chair highlighted to me um in
both cases we got into the schools
this was exactly the stuff in malden it
was exactly the stuff you would expect
kids coming out of school on the way
home yeah
um so we've got into the schools
um working with
um spencer's team as well to make sure
that we're getting the message across in
two ways not just as an enforcement
helps if you can hear me
so that's how we're progressing forwards
um we've been through we've talked
through all of the areas i was going to
talk through the work that we were going
forward which is still around
neighborhood watch increase but the fact
that coffee cops are back
um our links in with the schools
and the engagement day coming up in the
east there with bike marking
um
speeding which we've discussed the
number of ones with
the fact that we're executing more on
some drugs
and anxiety social behavior reported in
the
particularly southminster and bradwell
yeah recently targeted by officers and
the tri-service officer
um
i think my
cpt inspector has been a little bit um
uh thinking a little bit too much
because in her view it's been resolved
i've made that one
i'd say we've reduced it there's still
work to do
so happy for any questions thank you i
know there was some questions from
cancer stamp i believe they're being
dealt with just for the minutes and the
recording are they being addressed
separate famous times chairman yes i'll
write to you uh actually special and uh
he can obviously respond to the director
council stem thank you very much so um
have a team members council humor first
yeah so great great news as you say
what's going to happen in the high
street then with the
a shop you've taken over or
what's going to be happening here isn't
it no no the team's coming in here so
it's actually coming in the council
building
so so we currently have our local
policing team so the 24 7 guys
they're based here
um the space hasn't been adequate for a
considerable amount of time because of
the increase in officer numbers
and the excellent support we get with
our special constabulary and their
numbers
so we've been looking to grow the space
anyway
um and now with these extra officers we
need to grow the space um so my
understanding is we're at the final
stages of writing up the agreements and
i'm told i had a meeting with our
estates board and they said two months
to get everything in place
um around fittings i.t et cetera et
cetera so the space will be there hasten
to add the officers won't be there
as quickly
that's fantastic news thank you should
we come back
yeah is that no
these offices here is it yeah yeah i
understand that yeah yeah in these
offices here so um
the next thing is to convince our
transport team to give me some more
vehicles
that's the next one
[Music]
we're not going to have any tents out on
the back garden there then
you're going to get a few
new solid buildings
now i'm really really pleased to hear
that we're increasing the community
policing team
i mean i i used to have um i think she
was romanian but she was a cpso
and
she used to get so much information from
just walking around the community you
know around the precinct
around our estate and that and she got a
lot of feedback
but unfortunately she left the police
force
well stupidly to become a parish
councillors
but uh yeah she's not doing that either
now but i'm really really pleased at the
community team because
they really do get in with the community
and get a lot of feedback
and i have missed that
absolutely and yeah as i say for the
three years i've been here i've been
trying to get that so it feels like a
real win at the moment so um
yes
thank you and that was positive that's
brilliant it's lovely to end on on a
positive isn't it it really uh so much
for your five minutes i know listen
thank you so much i mean i'm sure
members were happy to note all the
reports and updates that we've been that
we've received they're all noted
gentlemen thank you so so much for
giving up your very valuable time to
come and talk to us tonight it really is
greatly appreciated and we'll talk to us
more to you about a gay community
liaison and i'll talk more to you about
bikes if that's okay i'm not talking to
you about
such about that thing
so um
some of your
crime stoppers meetings
and we'll see councillor humor at the
crime stoppers meeting so i don't have
any other items of business some
that are urgent so
ladies and gentlemen thank you again and
i now draw the meeting to close at 20
22.
you